-Welcome back.
We're here with Kate McKinnon.
And Kate,
I don't need to tell you this.
You were in "Barbie" this year.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, I was. Yeah.
-But I didn't know this,
that you and Greta Gerwig,
roommates in college.
Look at that.
-We were in the same suite.
-Okay, I'm gonna count it.
-We were in the same suite
with also two girls who...
God, they barfed in that tub.
-Yeah.
-There was just...
There was puke in that tub.
-Two tub barfers?
-Yeah. We didn't know that.
They were like,
two that got tacked on,
and my gosh.
-More than once,
they barfed in the tub?
-Yeah, a couple times.
-Wow.
-More than a couple times.
And I thought, "Oh, I can't
wait to get out of here."
-Yeah. So, Greta,
your old friend you've known
since your late teens,
calls you up to say
that she wants you to play
Weird Barbie.
-Right.
-That must have been
a very exciting call.
-It was very exciting,
and it was also like --
Well, she was like,
"I'm doing the Barbie movie."
And I was like, "Oh."
"Cool. Okay."
And she's like,
"I have a character for you."
And I was like, "Oh...okay."
And she was like, "It's --"
I was like, "What is it?"
And she was like,
"It's Weird Barbie."
And I was like, "Okay,
so it's a documentary.
My portion will be
a biopic of me."
And so I was like,
"Okay, yeah, fine."
-What was the inspiration
for, uh -- visually,
what did you want Weird Barbie?
-Well, so, Greta told me
that it was like the Barbie doll
that everyone had
that was messed up
where like,
you'd cut the hair off
and you'd burn it and, like,
mess the clothes up and stuff.
And I had a lot of experience
with that,
because my little sister
and her friends
had a lot of Barbie stuff
going on,
and there was one that they,
like, cut the hair off,
and she was always naked
and her leg
was always like, off.
And they called her Urinelle,
because someone at one point
had, I don't know.
-Based on the name, I do know.
-So I just thought,
well, if if there was
ever in my life a character
for me, that would be it.
-And you got --
We brought the doll.
-Oh, yeah.
-How did you feel when you knew
there was going to be
a Weird Barbie?
-Oh, fine. I mean --
-Yeah.
-Pretty normal. This is just --
-I mean, it wasn't
as exciting as Jug Day.
-No, nothing could be
as exciting as --
I'll take off the hair net.
Yeah, I guess she's also --
-I mean, you have to be --
I'd be pretty happy with
how this turned out.
-No, it's amazing.
It's incredible.
And you know,
the costumes were so fun
and the sets
were so fun and stuff,
and this is the hair
that I am going for.
It's on its way.
This is where I've always --
This is me in the woods.
That's what I am.
-Yeah.
-And what I've always been.
-Oh, my God. One-handed!
No. Kate, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am --
I'll tell you this.
I'll tell you this
before I let you go.
-What?
-I'm so jealous of everybody
who works at that show
that they get to get one
more week with Kate McKinnon,
because nobody did it better.
-Aww.
-And I'm so excited
to watch on Saturday.
-Thank you, Seth.
-What a delight
to have you here.
I missed you so very much.
I miss you too.
-You guys,
that's Kate McKinnon, everybody.
She's hosting "SNL" this weekend
with musical guest
Billie Eilish,
which airs live
on NBC and Peacock.
We'll be right back with
Carmelo Anthony
and The Kid Mero.